[Music]
it's a human thing
i'm kind of an expert what does it mean
the thing you just said come on i'll
show you some more stuff
mother of pearl you live up here
yeah me and my dad he's not even here a
whole lot so i pretty much just do
whatever i want
isn't it dangerous yeah it's the best
everything good is above the surface
like what else air
gravity also known as
the sky clouds the sun whoa
don't look at it just kidding definitely
look at it
how could my mother tell him about this
town with bloodthirsty lunatics
i still can't believe he would do this
it's not like him just keep your guard
up
there's going to be land monsters
everywhere
it's me you scared the scales off of me
geez
you're strong i'm sorry i'm just a
little on edge no i needed that
it really woke me up wow we look
horrifying ugh gross come on
let's find our song
if there is so much as a scratch oh
someone got lucky today hmm who got
lucky
out of towners huh let me welcome you
benvenutia porto rosso i'm delighted to
meet you number one
and number two i love your stylish
clothes
what did you get them a dead body dead
body
i'm kidding ah look senor vespa
senor vespa
five-time winner of the porto rosso cup
the porto rosa what
departuroso cap how do you think i paid
for my beautiful vespa
hey stop looking she's too beautiful for
you
hey i brought some friends for dinner is
there enough before
[Music]
oh what's wrong with you stupid
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you think he kills with those
anything that swims
mr jonathan today yeah that photo's a
fake
papa everyone pop that also pretends to
believe in sea monsters
well i'm not pretending
[Music]
um
[Music]
that was hard to watch you uh coming
do not go anywhere near the surface got
it
everything good is above the surface
walking
air the sky clouds the sun
whoa don't look at it just kidding
definitely look at it
have you ever gone to the human town
yeah
i'm kind of an expert
go start the club for losers
my name is julia marcovaldo we underdogs
have to look out for each other
what's under the dogs
this is my dad what do you think he
kills with those anything that swims
your life is so much cooler than mine
there's a million things you think
you can't do all you need is a chance to
try
something fishy with youtube
this is too dangerous
i know your problem you got a bruno in
your head a bruno say
silencio bruno sublencio broom louder
silence your bruiser
can you still hear him nope just you
good
now hang on
[Music]
you do it now just say the thing what's
wrong with you stupido
lucca is the story of friendships that
are authentic
and only found around a certain age we
underdogs have to look out for each
other right underdogs
i love this moment in a young person's
life
having someone push you out of your
comfort zone to discover yourself
there's a certain innocence to this it's
really kind of beautiful come on
i had the lack of meeting my best friend
alberto when i was 11.
he had a ton of passion and was
consciously testing his own fears
who's holding the ramp the turtle i
wonder if i would have had the courage
to
go and chase my career in animation and
i know my best friend
i really love watching the friendship
between luca julia and alberto
i'm hoping that it will bring back a lot
of memories for people of summers when
they were kids
my birthday is in the summer so a lot of
really really good
childhood memories of summertime and it
was always a cool party
let's go swim i guess that's how humans
swim
that's embarrassing some kids go away to
camp and you're like
where my dogs at but then the key ones
that are in town they like to party
these are the friendships that teach us
lessons fill your self-esteem
and you have like the sense of belonging
i got friends that believe in me who
push me like i would tell them an idea
that i have and they'd be like
make it do it this movie is the perfect
example of that
these friendships that help us find
ourselves that is really at the heart of
the story of
elgato imagine a world where summer
isn't just the season
quite a state of mind in luca we want to
take you
to this wonderful nostalgic look on
italian summers
classic human town pretty cool right
luca is about these two
sea monsters and they experience the
world outside the water
have you ever gone to the human town
most of the story on land is in a
fictional place called porto rosso
just sounds nice doesn't it
when people dream of going on a perfect
vacation
that's literally what porterosa is come
on i'll show you some more stuff
pixar has a history of wanting to make
our films feel authentic and so part of
that is doing research
taking the team to italy was such a
pleasure promise you told me everything
you see
sorry too much never our pixar research
trips
make us look like very odd tourists
because we're looking at the kind of
details that we're trying to capture we
want it to be
like a postcard you can jump into and
really feel immersed by
the laundry and the wind kids having
watermelon and people having their
espresso
espresso
i love miyazaki's movies the texture the
details
the way he draws has been a great
inspiration for me
when i saw enrico's short la luna he
calls our attention
to things around us that are beautiful i
love that this film is an expansion of
that feeling it's so beautiful
yes we need it luca will without a doubt
transport you to this vibrant world
watching it i felt like i was there wow
makes you want to move daily i think we
should all live there sign me up for
that like right now
this is gonna be the best summer ever
[Music]
you